This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加梅斯（Kear Games）主持的《艰难成长》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方绝对不安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人披着盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。听听如何了解
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
以艰难的方式在iHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中心理坚韧、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更加充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个高产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, lovely people. How are we going on this fine day wherever you're listening in the world? Thanks for joining. Thanks for tuning in to the psychology of your 20s. It's lovely to have you here. This week, we're talking about emotional intelligence or EQ, as some people call it, and why it's different from normal intelligence, from our IQ. This topic, it's different because, well, maybe it's not different.
在iHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《闺蜜们》。相信我，宝贝。你好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。各位可爱的人，你们好。无论你在世界的哪个角落收听，今天过得怎么样？感谢加入。感谢收听《你二十岁的心理学》。很高兴能在这里与你相聚。本周，我们来聊聊情商（EQ），正如有些人所称的那样，以及它为什么不同于普通智商（IQ）。这个话题之所以不同，是因为，嗯，也许它其实没什么不同。
I think it's kind of common with some of the topics we talk about, but it's just as important in our 20s as it is in the rest of our lives. But the reason I want to talk about it in the context of our 20s is, is because this decade is when our brain is in those final kind of stages of development, when our frontal lobe is yet to form, when it's in its most critical kind of stage to build those final skills, those final neurons, and with that, where we can kind of perfect our emotional intelligence. And I just thought it would be really, really interesting. I think it's such a crucial part of success in life, of achieving the things that you want, having healthy
我想这与我们讨论的一些话题很常见，但它在我们的二十岁就像在生活的其他阶段一样重要。不过，我想在二十岁的背景下探讨这个话题，是因为在这个十年里，我们的大脑正处于发育的最后阶段，我们的额叶尚未完全形成，正处于构建这些最终技能、最终神经元的关键阶段，随之而来的是，我们可以借此完善我们的情商。我只是觉得这会非常非常有趣。我认为这是人生成功、实现心中所愿、拥有健康
relationships, all the things that I think are the base of happiness and success. And I think a really common misconception about emotional intelligence is that like intelligence to some degree or like some other innate skill, it's not something that can be taught. It's not something that can be developed. What you're born with, the emotional intelligence that you're born with is what you get. It's the cards that you're dealt for the rest of your life. And that is just totally. totally untrue. It is fundamentally a skill. Emotional intelligence is a skill and it can be learned. You can alter how you see people, how you see yourself and how you react to them. Although there are some people who perhaps are more naturally adept the same way that there
人系，所有这些我认为是幸福与成功基石的事物中至关重要的一部分。而且我认为关于情商的一个非常普遍的误解是，就像某种程度上的智商或其他某种先天技能一样，它不是可以教出来的。它不是可以发展的东西。你天生带有什么情商，那就是什么。这是你余生拿到的牌。这完全、完全是错误的。它根本上是一种技能。情商是一种技能，它是可以学习的。你可以改变你看待他人、看待自己以及对他们做出反应的方式。尽管有些人可能天生更擅长此道，就像有
are people who are better at sports or have more analytical brains or more creative brains. and that stuff is really to do with your upbringing, your temperament, the personality you are kind of dealt with upon conception and upon birth. That is a huge misconception and there is a huge misconception around emotional intelligence being something that is stagnant, being something that is permanent, what you're born with, the skills that you're born with is what you get, which is completely untrue. We're going to talk about that today. how do you curate and develop and build emotional intelligence in your 20s because it is so
人更擅长体育运动，或者拥有更具分析性或创造性的大脑一样。而这些确实与你的成长背景、气质、你在受孕和出生时被赋予的性格有关。这是一个巨大的误解，人们对情商存在一个巨大的误解，认为它是停滞不前的，是永恒的，天生拥有什么技能就是什么，这完全是错误的。我们今天就要谈谈这个。如何在二十岁时培养、发展和建立情商，因为它是
foundational and critical for every year, every decade, every emotional experience going forward. So emotional intelligence, it's an interesting kind of corner of psychology because unlike some of the other topics I talk about, I focus a lot on positive psychology and social psychology. emotional intelligence is normally talked about in relation to organizational psychology. You may have guessed what that is, but organizational psychology really has a lot to do with the workplace and how we interact with people in the workplace and how leaders are born, how we influence people. But it is a lot more general than that. I think that beyond the workplaces, perhaps, where it has its greatest relevance and its
对未来每一年、每一个十年、每一次情感体验都至关重要且基础的。所以情商，它是心理学中一个有趣的角落，因为不像我谈论的其他一些话题，我专注于积极心理学和心理学。情商通常与组织心理学联系在一起。你可能已经猜到那是什么了，但组织心理学确实与职场、我们在职场中如何与人交往、领导者是如何诞生的、我们如何影响他人有很大关系。但它远不止于此。我认为除了职场之外，这或许是它最相关、最
greatest applicability. And there's been some huge talk around emotional intelligence recently. It's kind of become very popular part of the psychobabble, as we would say, as more people begin discovering it, begin discovering its applicability, beyond the workplace, beyond corporate life, and see that it is so fundamental to all these other areas that are beyond how we make money and how we control the tides of business, I think. So I think that first kind of came about in like the 1960s and 70s, but it's been popularized a lot more recently. And with that, we're seeing a lot of cultural trends around emotional intelligence also emerge. It's now taught,
最具普适性的地方。最近关于情商的讨论非常热烈。它已经成为心理学流行语（如果我们这么说的话）中非常受欢迎的一部分，随着越来越多的人开始发现它、开始发现在职场和企业生活之外的普适性，并看到它对于除了我们如何赚钱、如何掌控商业风云之外的其他所有领域都如此至关重要。所以我认为这最早出现在20世纪60和70年代左右，但最近才变得非常流行。随之而来的是，我们也看到许多围绕情商的文化趋势正在涌现。它现在被教导，
you know, in Harvard Business School and Harvard Business School and other business schools. and I think it's one of those things where I've always had these discussions with my friends where at uni would say that person's really intelligent, but they have pretty low EQ. They're not very emotionally intelligent. So it's part of that distinction, I think, these days that we have between, I don't want to say natural intelligence, but academic intelligence and what we traditionally think of as intelligence, and those more soft, nuanced skills around how we relate to others. even though it's taught at Harvard Business School, I think that it does have a lot of relevance
你知道的，在哈佛商学院和其他商学院。我认为这就是其中之一，我经常和朋友们讨论，在大学里我们会说那个人真的很聪明，但他们的情商很低。他们不是很有情商。所以我认为，如今我们在自然智力（我不想这么说）也就是学术智力（我们传统上认为的智力）与那些围绕我们如何与他人相处更柔软、更细腻的技能之间做出了这种区分。尽管哈佛商学院教授这个，但我认为它仍然具有很大的相关性
to all those who aren't there. If you are there, tell me what they're saying about it. Tell me if I'm accurate. But it is really, really important. And it differs from IQ in so many ways. Like I said, IQ we often think of as analytical skills, as the way that we process factual information, how we absorb information, our memory, how we use it. But emotionally, intelligence really rests in our social relationships and in our own emotional awareness, which we'll talk about later on, and how we interact with people, how we influence people beyond our general knowledge and beyond how we process information. So let's take a bit more of a deep dive into the components of emotional intelligence in our 20s, the benefits of a high EQ, and how to
对于所有不在那里的人来说。如果你在那里，告诉我他们在说什么。告诉我我说得准不准确。但这真的非常非常重要。它在很多方面都不同于智商。就像我说的，我们通常认为智商是分析能力，是我们处理事实信息的方式，我们如何吸收信息、记忆力以及我们如何使用它。但情商实际上立足于我们的社会关系以及我们自己的情感意识（我们稍后会讨论），以及我们如何与人互动、如何超越我们的常识和信息处理方式去影响他人。让我们更深入地探讨一下二十岁时情商的各个组成部分、高情商的好处，以及如何
develop your emotional intelligence even further, if that's something you're interested in. So firstly, let's get our basic information down. What is EQ? What is emotional intelligence? Well, at its most primitive kind of basic level, emotional intelligence refers to our ability to understand, use and manage our own emotions in positive ways that affect us and affect others. It kind of encompasses how to communicate effectively, how to have those healthy, positive relationships, how to succeed at your personal goals. This really interesting study found that when children, when kids had higher emotional intelligence, they did a lot better at school. They did a lot better socially, obviously, but academically as well. It's such a crucial component to succeeding in the
进一步培养你的情商，如果这是你感兴趣的话题。首先，让我们搞清楚基础知识。什么是情商？什么是情商？好吧，在最原始、最基本的层面上，情商指的是我们理解、使用和以积极的方式管理自己情绪的能力，这些情绪会影响我们自己和他人。它大致包括如何有效沟通、如何建立健康积极的关系、如何在个人目标上取得成功。这项非常有趣的研究发现，当孩子们拥有更高的情商时，他们在学校表现得更好。他们在社交方面显然表现得更好，在学业上也是如此。这是在
world and to having a healthy professional life, being able to follow through with your commitments, and also making informed decisions. So emotional intelligence really involves those core areas of the frontal lobe, which are responsible for how we see the world, how we interpret the world, and how we process our emotions and make decisions based on what they're telling us. So emotional intelligence, it has four main components. These are self-awareness, self-regulation, social awareness, and social regulation or control. I don't really like the word,
世界上取得成功、拥有健康职业生活、能够兑现承诺以及做出明智决策的关键组成部分。因此，情商确实涉及额叶的核心区域，这些区域负责我们如何看待世界、如何解释世界、如何处理情绪并根据它们告诉我们的信息做出决策。所以情商有四个主要组成部分。它们是自我意识、自我调节、社会意识以及社会调节或控制。我其实不太喜欢这个词，
control in this situation, I think it suggests that emotional intelligence is something that we want to develop and build in order to influence people for our own gain. But it's more about leading and it's more about being able to dance around other people's feelings and understand their emotional concerns and their emotional needs. So emotional intelligence really starts with you. It starts with self-awareness. And self-awareness, I think, is something that is misunderstood in psychology or in those who kind of dabble in psychology to a pretty large degree. In some, we often say it as, you know, being able to recognize our faults, knowing ourselves pretty well, but it's a little bit deeper than that.
在这种情况下使用“控制”，我认为它暗示情商是我们为了谋取私利而影响他人的一种东西。但它更多的是关于领导力，更多的是关于能够绕过他人的感受，理解他们的情感关切和情感需求。所以情商确实始于你自己。它始于自我意识。我认为，自我意识在心理学中，或者在那些对心理学略知一二的人当中，在很大程度上被误解了。在某些情况下，我们通常认为它是，你知道的，能够认识到自己的缺点，对自己相当了解，但它比这要更深一点。
Self-awareness is really about being able to recognize and understand your own emotions, being able to name your emotions, but also know why you're feeling them. it gives you so much information about the world to have an understanding of how you cognitively react to things and it is the foundation of emotional intelligence being able to respond effectively not to what others are thinking but at the very beginning what you're thinking a big part about self-awareness i think is realizing that all of life's events everything that you experience everything that's hard or good or sad or happy, these events are innately neutral. They don't have any natural, intuitive, assigned meaning until we evaluate it as either good or bad.
自我意识实际上是关于能够认识和理解你自己的情绪，能够为你的情绪命名，同时也知道你为什么会有这种感觉。了解自己对事物的认知反应会为你提供大量关于世界的信息，这是情商的基础，能够做出有效的反应，不是对别人的想法做出反应，而是在一开始就对你自己的想法做出反应。我认为自我意识很大一部分在于意识到生活中的所有事件，你经历的一切，所有艰难的、美好的、悲伤的或快乐的事情，这些事件本质上都是中立的。它们没有任何天然的、直观的、被赋予的意义，直到我们将其评估为好或坏。
And that's an internal process that creates feelings and it's responsible for how we feel and react. So when something happens in our lives, there is an unconscious evaluation that occurs in our that assigns that event as either being positive or negative. And that information, that processing, the meaning we assigned to an event, comes from external sources, what we're expected to feel, but also our own learning and how we've responded to things in the past, how things made us feel in the past, so that we have a basis for knowing how we should react
这是一个产生感觉的内部过程，它决定了我们的感受和反应。因此，当我们的生活中发生某事时，我们的脑海中会进行一次无意识的评估，将该事件归类为积极的或消极的。这些信息、处理过程以及我们赋予事件的意义，来自于外部来源，即我们的期望感受，同时也来自于我们自身的学习以及我们过去对事情的反应、过去事情给我们带来的感受，以便我们有一个基础来了解我们应该如何反应
in a socially appropriate manner or in a way that matches how you expect yourself to feel. But being able to recognize that all events are innately neutral, this allows you to identify why you're having a feeling in that moment. And what is that feeling kind of attached to? Is it a normal feeling? Is it something that seems appropriate given the circumstances? Or is it based on learning and based on experiences? So that's the whole thing about self-awareness. is being able to look at your emotions, name your emotions and understand why you're feeling it. That is the bedrock of emotional intelligence. Once you're able to identify your feelings, once you have that high level of self-awareness,
以一种社会合适的方式，或者以一种符合你对自己预期感受的方式。但能够认识到所有事件本质上都是中立的，这能让你识别出为什么你在那一刻会有这种感觉。这种感觉究竟依附于什么？这是一种正常的感觉吗？鉴于当前的环境，这看起来合适吗？还是基于学习和经验？这就是自我意识的全部内容。就是能够审视你的情绪，为你的情绪命名并理解你为什么会有这种感觉。这是情商的基石。一旦你能够识别自己的感觉，一旦你有了高水平的自我意识，
the other building block of emotional intelligence, the next kind of core ingredient is self-regulation. It's all fine and good and well to be able to recognize your emotions, to be able to sit back and say, oh, I'm mad and I'm mad because of this, and this is triggering me because of this, and being able to know their source, whether it's endogenous or exogenous, internal or external. But that is really no use in terms of your broader emotional intelligence and ability to relate to others unless you're able to control your impulsive feelings,
情商的另一个基石，下一个核心要素就是自我调节。能够识别自己的情绪固然很好，能够退一步说，哦，我很生气，我生气是因为这个，这个触发了我的这个情绪，并且能够知道它们的来源，无论是内源性的还是外源性的、内部的还是外部的，这都很好。但就你更广泛的情商和与他人相处的能力而言，这其实毫无用处，除非你能够控制自己冲动的感受，
to control your behaviors and manage emotions in healthy ways. And then from that, being able to take initiative and to follow through on your commitments, relate and be able to relate to others and adapt to your changing circumstances. So this is about self-regulation. You've had that feeling, you've identified it, but the next step is what you do with it. How do you react to how you're feeling? And are you able to bring that into your broader life, into what you want from life, and integrate it in a positive way?
控制自己的行为并以健康的方式管理情绪。然后在此基础上，能够采取主动并兑现承诺，与他人建立联系并与之相处，以及适应不断变化的环境。这就是自我调节。你已经有了那种感觉，你已经识别了它，但下一步就是你如何处理它。你如何对自己的感受做出反应？你是否能够将这一点带入你更广泛的生活中，带入你对生活的诉求中，并以积极的方式将其整合？
Emotional regulation kind of captures all of this. It captures being adaptive to changing circumstances. and it's different from self-awareness because self-awareness is basically recognition, but self-regulation is action, is action in response to that recognition. So on the back of these two internal processes, we also have social awareness. Now, this is probably, I think, where most people see emotional intelligence as lying, as this is where a lot of people, I think, are misguided in thinking that emotional intelligence, is actually social awareness. And in some ways it is, but the critical thing about those two prior
情绪调节可以说是囊括了这一切。它囊括了适应不断变化的环境。这与自我意识不同，因为自我意识基本上是识别，而自我调节则是行动，是针对这种识别所做出的行动。在这两个内在过程的基础上，我们还有社会意识。现在，这可能就是我认为大多数人认为情商所在的地方，这也是我认为很多人在认为情商实际上就是社会意识时被误导的地方。在某些方面确实如此，但这两者之前的关键之处在于，
ideas is that you can't actually have social awareness without having self-awareness and self-regulation. You can't show empathy, you can't react to social cues or feel socially comfortable without first understanding how other people might be feeling emotions because you have felt them and you can recognize them and name them yourself. So social awareness really encompasses being able to understand other people's emotions and their emotional concerns and their needs and their social concerns and how you can provide them or maybe take them away. So you begin to see yourself not as a sole individual, not as your own feelings, but see your feelings and how you might react in relationship to other people, both recognizing how your reactions affect them,
观点是，如果你没有自我意识和自我调节，你实际上就不可能拥有社会意识。你无法表现出同理心，你无法对社会线索做出反应，或者在社交场合感到舒适，除非你首先理解其他人可能会有什么样的情绪感受，因为你曾经感受过它们，并且你自己就能识别和命名它们。因此，社会意识实际上包括能够理解他人的情绪、他们的情感关切和需求、他们的社会关切，以及你如何能够满足它们或者也许消除它们。所以你开始不再把自己看作一个孤立的个体，不再只关注自己的感受，而是看到你的感受以及你可能会如何反应，
but also how you might actually understand their reactions a lot better by looking internally and thinking, how would I react to that situation? What would I be feeling? And that's social awareness. A critical thing about this element of EQ is that it's the hardest to learn. It's the most intuitive. I know I'm kind of contradicting myself and, you know, I said that emotional awareness and emotional intelligence is something that we can learn, which it is.
但同时也通过向内看并思考“面对这种情况我会作何反应？我会作何感受”，从而更好地理解他们的反应。这就是社会意识。EQ这一要素的关键在于，它是最难学习的。它是最直观的。我知道我有点自相矛盾，你知道的，我曾说过情感意识和情商是我们可以学习的东西，确实如此，
but the hardest part of it is being able to apply that to other people because other people are unpredictable as I always say this to my friend Aaron but people aren't always going to react the way that you would to a situation people have their own cultural experiences their own personal learning experiences that have taught them to behave in different ways and reaction to their feelings it's also the part that is most kind of biologically determined social awareness is normally something that some people have at a higher level compared to others. And a good example of this is people with autism who might struggle with social awareness. That's no fault of theirs. It's not like they're not trying hard.
但其中最难的部分是能够将其应用到其他人身上，因为正如我总是对我的朋友亚伦所说的那样，人是不可预测的，人们并不总是会像你那样对某种情况做出反应，人们有他们自己的文化经历，他们自己的个人学习经历，这些经历教会了他们在对自己的感受做出反应时表现出不同的行为。这也是在生物学上最难确定的部分。社会意识通常是某些人天生水平较高的东西。一个很好的例子就是自闭症患者，他们可能在社会意识方面挣扎。这不是他们的错。并不是说他们不够努力。
It's that it is something that is more innate. And it is the most difficult component of EQ to master. But once you do, you get that final stage, that final step, that final component, which is where ideas of leadership and influence really come into it. And that's relationship management, regulating other people. So in this final stage, you know how to develop and maintain good relationships. You can communicate clearly, you can inspire and influence others, and you can manage their emotions and needs because you understand them.
而是这确实是一项更具先天性的东西。它是掌握EQ最具挑战性的组成部分。但一旦你做到了，你就会进入那个最后的阶段，最后一步，最后一个组成部分，也就是领导力和影响力概念真正发挥作用的地方。那就是关系管理，也就是对其他人的调节。所以在最后这个阶段，你知道如何发展和维持良好的关系。你可以清晰地沟通，你可以激励和影响他人，你可以管理他们的情绪和需求，因为你理解他们。
You have that self-awareness and that social awareness. And with that, much like self-regulose. you can apply it to your interactions with others. These final two steps are just, I think the thing that really trips the most people over because social awareness is an isolated activity. You can kind of do that yourself by sitting down and evaluating your feelings and journaling and going to therapy or doing whatever you need to do to connect with your own emotions and feelings. But being able to learn what they look like in others is a much more difficult task because
你拥有那种自我意识和社会意识。随之而来的是，就像自我调节一样。你可以将其应用到你与他人的互动中。我认为，最后这两个步骤恰恰是最容易让人栽跟头的地方，因为社会意识是一项孤立的活动。你可以通过坐下来评估自己的感受、写日记、去看心理医生或者做任何你需要的事情来与自己的情绪和感觉建立连接，从而独自完成这一步。但是，要学会在别人身上发现这些情绪则是一项困难得多的任务，因为
emotional reactions and experiences, as we said, are not universal. Okay, so whilst all these components that we've talked about are crucial and important to emotional intelligence, to being able to relate to others, some people may only have one or two components, and that's where they kind of get stuck. Maybe they're someone who can influence people, but they're still really aloof and have low social awareness, although it's probably unlikely that they're intentionally influencing people, they still have that capability. They still have that capacity, despite being low in social regulation and social awareness. And on the flip side, you can have a high degree of self-awareness, really understand and have deep knowledge
正如我们所说，情绪反应和体验并不是普遍适用的。好了，虽然我们讨论的所有这些组成部分对情商、对与他人相处都至关重要且重要，但有些人可能只有一两个组成部分，而这正是他们卡住的地方。也许他们是那种能够影响他人的人，但他们仍然非常冷漠，社会意识很低，尽管他们可能不是故意去影响别人的，但他们仍然具备这种能力。尽管他们在社会调节和社会意识方面很低，但他们仍然拥有这种潜能。另一方面，你也可以拥有高度的自我意识，真正理解并深入了解你的感受以及你的情绪如何与世界相关联，但仍然无法管理关系，无法进入我们正在讨论的社会调节要素中。所以这有点像一个四件拼图，如果你缺少其中一块，如果你漏掉了一块，我们的情商可以说就是不成熟的。因此，所有的拼图都同样至关重要。你不能只是跳过某个步骤。但另一个需要注意的是，情商也高度依赖于他人。它是具有关系性的。
of how you feel and how your emotions relate to the world, but still remain unable to manage relationships and unable to step into that social regulation element that we're talking about. So it is kind of a four-piece puzzle where if you don't have one piece, if you're missing one of them, your emotional intelligence, we would say, is underdeveloped. So all pieces are just as crucial. You can't just skip a step. But the other caveat is that emotional intelligence is also highly dependent on others. It is relational.
也许到目前为止这已经很明显了，但如果其他人不存在，你就无法影响他人；如果他们一开始就没有这些情绪，你就无法理解他们的情绪、与他们建立联系并与他们保持良好的关系。所以是的，它是极其具有关系性的，它取决于其他人的反应和他们的感受。你可能具备情商的所有组成部分，但假设你和一个精神病患者或完全缺乏自我意识的人交往。他们会挣扎，而你要想在他们面前展现你那美妙的高情商，也会非常挣扎。我认识一个这样的人，他真的没有什么自我意识。要满足他们的情感需求、理解他们的感受真的很难，
Maybe that's been pretty clear so far, but you can't influence others if other people don't exist and you can't understand their emotions and relate to them and have good relationships with them if they didn't have those emotions in the first place. So yeah, it's incredibly relational and it's dependent on how other people are reacting and their feelings. You might have all components of EQ, but say you have a relationship with someone who's a psychopath or completely lacking in self-awareness. They will struggle and you will struggle to display your beautifully high levels of EQ with them. I knew someone like this who had really low self-awareness. It's really hard to meet their emotional needs and to understand how they're feeling
因为他们自己甚至都意识不到这一点。那个人可能不确定他们的情感需求是什么，或者如果他们是那种具有精神病态、无法产生同理心或没有稳定情绪的人，他们可能会有失调的社会和情感需求。所以，即使你是一个专家，即使你非常熟练并且拥有情商所需的所有工具，驾驭这些关系仍然非常困难。就像我说的，这是具有关系性的。我能想到的另一个例子是，如果你在职场中（情商经常在这里受到审视），外面有一些非常喜欢挑起冲突的人。我们在其他一些剧集中讨论过这一点。喜欢挑起冲突的人是那些
because they don't even recognize it themselves. That person probably is unsure of what their emotional needs are or if they're someone who's psychopathic or can't have empathy or doesn't have consistent emotions, they might have disturbed social and emotional needs. So it is really hard to navigate those relationships, even if you're an expert, even if you're really skilled and have all of the tools that you would need for emotional intelligence. Like I said, it's relational. It might also be another instance that I can think of is if you're in the workplace, which where emotional intelligence is often investigated, there are some really conflict-seeking people out there. We've talked about this in some of our other episodes. Conflict-seeking people are people who
通过制造小题大做、与人吵架和八卦而感到兴奋、振奋并获得大量刺激的人。如果你不是那样的人，这些家伙将极难被调节、被影响或与他们建立联系，因为你永远无法理解他们的视角。你不是一个喜欢冲突的人。如果你不喜欢对抗，那么去管理或理解一个喜欢对抗的人的情绪将是一项相当艰巨的任务，即使你在所感受到的情绪方面拥有高度的自我意识。但如果你想想一个情商极高、对感知非常熟练的人，他们可能仍然能够处理这种情况，或者在这些类型的人周围游刃有余。给那个人
are excited and exhilarated and get a lot of stimulation from creating fuss and having fights with people and gossiping. These people are going to be really hard to regulate or to influence or to relate to if you're not someone like that because you're never going to understand. their perspective. You're not a conflict-seeking person. If you don't like confrontation, managing the emotions or understanding the emotions of someone who is, is going to be a pretty hard task, even if you have high levels of self-awareness in relations to the emotions you feel. But if you think about someone who has really high EQ, who's very skilled at perception, they may still be able to manage this or dance around these kinds of people. Give that person
一个有冲突需求的人一点体验，而又不会扰乱自己和他人的平静，因为他们经历过其他情绪困境，并且他们已经能够培养出那种技能以及对不断变化的环境的反应能力。那么，拥有高情商、成为那些能够毫不费力地驾驭所有情况的人有哪些好处呢？好吧，情商，正如我之前已经说过的，它会影响诸如你在工作或学校的表现等方面。你可以非常轻松地驾驭职场的复杂社交关系。你可以领导和激励他人，在职业生涯中脱颖而出。情商高的人
who has a need for conflict a little taste without disrupting the peace and others, because they have experienced other emotional situations and they've been able to cultivate that skill and that response to changing circumstances. So what are some of the benefits of having high emotional intelligence, being one of those people who can navigate all situations effortlessly? Well, emotional intelligence, like I've already said, it affects things like your performance at work or school. You can really easily navigate the social complexities of a workplace. You can lead and motivate others, excel in your career. People with
通常在大多数工作指标上得分更高。他们在诸如面试之类的事情上表现更好。他们更擅长管理内部冲突。它还对其他一些事情产生真正的影响，比如你的身体健康和心理健康。因此，如果你无法管理自己的情绪，你可能也没有管理好自己的压力。这可能会导致一些相当严重的健康问题。因此，正如我们所知，失控的压力会升高血压，当我们有高水平的皮质醇时会抑制免疫系统，从而增加心脏病发作和中风等风险，并加速衰老过程。这就是自我意识这一组成部分对你健康的其他方面非常重要的原因。因为如果你无法识别自己的
EQ often test higher on most job indicators. They're better at things like job interviews. They're better at managing internal conflict. It also really influences some other things like your physical health and your mental health. So if you're unable to manage your emotional, you're probably not managing your stress either. And this can lead to some pretty serious health problems. So uncontrolled stress, as we know, raises blood pressure, suppresses the immune system when we have high levels of cortisol and therefore increases things like the risk of heart attacks and strokes and speeds up the aging process. So that's where that self-awareness component is really important to the other areas of your health. Because if you aren't able to recognize how you're
感觉，认识到是什么在影响你。你可能会体验到更大的压力和更大的情绪唤醒，这也会对心理健康造成影响。失控的情绪和压力还会影响你的情感感受，使你更容易受到焦虑和抑郁的影响。如果你能够理解并适应或管理你的情绪，那么你就能够建立更牢固的关系，这会阻止你感到孤独和孤立。它能让你对自己的情感体验有更多的掌控力，改善你的人际关系，最后还有你的社会智能。是的，从这一集以及我们到目前为止讨论的内容中，如果你还看不出来的话，情商和社会智能是紧密相连的。与你的情绪保持
feeling, recognize what is influencing you. You might experience greater stress and greater arousal and that also contributes to mental health. Uncontrolled emotions and stress can also impact how you feel emotionally making you more vulnerable to anxiety and depression. And if you're able to understand and get comfortable with or manage your emotions, then you're able to form stronger relationships which stops you from feeling lonely and isolated. gives you more control over your emotional experiences, improves your relationships, and also finally, your social intelligence. Yes, emotional and social intelligence, if you couldn't tell from this episode and what we've talked about so far, are very much connected. And being in tune
一致绝对具有社会目的，正如我们从社会意识和社会调节组成部分中所看到的那样。它将你与其他人以及你周围的世界联系起来，使你能够识别，你知道的，朋友还是敌人，你可以衡量另一个人对你的兴趣，追求更健康的社交关系，通过社交沟通平衡你的神经系统，并感到真正的被爱和快乐。所以情商可能是它与一般智力的另一个重要区别，
with your emotions definitely serves a social purpose, as we can see from that social awareness and social regulation component. It connects you to other people and the world around you, and enables you to recognize, you know, friend from foe, you can measure another person's interest in you, pursue healthier relationships, balance your nervous system through social communication, and feel really loved and happy. So emotional intelligence is probably another important difference
它更多地与一种普遍的幸福感、平静感、舒适感有关，并且能够驾驭生活所抛给你的各种事情。所以这次谈话的一个重要部分以及我做出的一个重要承诺是，我要告诉你如何提高你的情商。因此，我们从那四个关键组成部分的角度来讨论情商是有原因的，因为它们同样至关重要，但你也可以通过专注于每一个组成部分来建立你的情商。所以从自我意识开始，管理压力只是
it has to just general intelligence is it's more linked to just a general sense of well-being and peace and comfort and being able to navigate what life kind of thing. throws at you. So a big part of this conversation and a big promise I made was I was going to tell you how you can increase your EQ. So there was a reason we talked about emotional intelligence in terms of those four key components because they're all equally crucial, but you can also build your EQ by focusing on each one of them. So starting at self-awareness, managing your stress is just the
培养情商的第一步。能够识别自己的情绪同样非常重要。如果你无法克服这一点，如果你无法做到这一点，你就不太可能提高你的情商。你应该能够管理愤怒、悲伤、恐惧和快乐等核心感受，以便体验全方位的情感体验，同时也知道你对它们有何反应。所以要问的问题是，当我遇到某种情绪时，我该如何反应？这些情绪是否伴随着身体感觉？你体验到的是单独的感受和情绪，还是可以同时感受到它们？所以愤怒和悲伤，这真的很有趣。有些人把它们当作不同的感觉来体验，无法同时感受到它们，
step to building emotional intelligence. Being able to recognize your emotions as well, that's also really crucial. And if you can't get over that, if you're unable to do that, it's unlikely that you'll be able to increase your emotional intelligence. So you should be able to manage core feelings like anger, sadness, fear, and joy in order to feel the full breadth of emotional experiences, but also know how you react to them. So the questions to ask are, when I encounter an emotion, how do I react? Are those emotions accompanied by physical sensations? Do you experience individual feelings and emotion or can you feel them at the same time? So anger and sadness, it's really interesting. Some people feel them as different sensations and can't feel them at the same time,
而另一些人则把它们当作一种感觉来体验，并能拥有那种细微差别。就我个人而言，我无法同时感到生气和难过。这是两种不同的体验。还有一个问题是，你能体验到强烈的情绪吗？它们是什么感觉？所有这些都有助于你关注自己的情绪。这是培养情商的最大因素。许多科学家和心理学家给出的最大建议是，当你感受到一种情绪时，你是否有这样一个过程：坐下来，识别它，理解你为什么会有这种感觉，并且能够意识到，它是内部的吗？我能为此做点什么吗？还是说？它是外部的，我应该改变我环境中的某些东西吗？这至关重要。一旦你理解了
whereas others feel them as one and can have that kind of nuance. Me personally, I can't be angry and sad at the same time. It's a different experience. There's also, that question of can you experience intense emotions? What do they feel like? And all of this is contributing to you being able to pay attention to your emotions. That is the biggest factor in building EQ. And the biggest recommendation a lot of scientists and psychologists have is when you feel an emotion, do you have a process for sitting back, recognizing it, understanding why you're feeling that way, and being able to realize, is it internal? Can I do something about it? Or do you? visit external and should I change something about my environment? And that's crucial. Once you understand
你的大脑是如何经历这些关键路径和模式的，这才是你拥有高水平自我意识的时候，真正花时间评估你的所作所为、你的反应方式、你的反应是什么。为了调动你的情商，你还必须能够利用你的情绪对你的行为做出建设性的决定，即自我管理。那是第二个组成部分。所以一旦你能够识别你的情绪，你就必须能够用它们做点什么，对吧？你必须能够积极地对它们做出反应，这样你就不会失去对情绪的控制，也不会失去把事情想清楚以及深思熟虑、恰当行事的能力。培养这一点、特别是培养你对压力和情感激烈体验的反应能力的一个非常好的方法是，对究竟是什么在信息中让你感到不安保持高度的心智觉知，为什么它会凌驾于你的想法和自我控制之上。曾经有人给过我一个很好的建议：永远不要在当下做出反应。如果你正在面试，一定要花点时间，退后一步思考，真正思考你正在感受到什么情绪，你的主要反应是什么，以及我该如何谨慎地回应。此时此刻最好的自己会怎么做？应用这一点的绝佳方法是，当你身处某个时刻时，你并不在。
how your brain flows through those key pathways and those patterns, that's when you have high levels of self-awareness, really taking time to evaluate what you do, how you respond, what your reaction is. In order to engage your emotional intelligence, you also have to be able to use your emotions to make constructive decisions about your behavior, self-management. That was the second component. So once you're able to recognize your emotions, you have to be able to do something with them, right? You have to be able to respond to them positively so you don't lose control of your emotions or your ability to think things through and to act thoughtfully and appropriately. A really good way to kind of build this and to build particularly your reaction to stressful
情感苛刻的情况下，也许你正在和某人争吵，花几分钟，花一天时间，花几个小时，退后一步思考，在这种情况下，最高版本的自己、最具情商版本的自己会怎么做？所以下一个关键技能，我们讨论过的是社会意识，你识别和解释他人线索的能力，能够与他们沟通、感受到与他们的联系并理解他们的感受。在这种情况下，正念是情感和社会意识的盟友。为了建立社会意识，你需要对其他人正在感受和经历的事情保持正念，并且你需要能够将你自己的经验应用到他们的反应中。会有微妙的
and emotionally intense experiences is to stay really mindful of what exactly is upsetting you about the information you're receiving and why is it overriding your thoughts and self-control. A big piece of advice that someone once gave me is never react in the moment. If you're in a job interview, always like take a moment, step back and think, really think about what emotion you're feeling, what's your main reaction and how do I respond to that cautiously. What would the best version of myself do here? A really great way to apply this is when you are in a moment, you are in a moment, you're not.
其他人的情绪转变正在发生，你必须能够识别它们。你必须能够识别他们的目标和目的。而这正是同理心真正发挥作用的地方。培养同理心这一核心技能是如此关键。它或许是最关键的部分，就像社会意识是情商中最难的部分一样。同理心是一件很难精心培育的事情。它很难发展。但它实际上与自我调节处于相同的领域。退后一步，绘制心智图。如果我处于这种情况下，我会是什么？感受，依靠你自己的自我意识去思考我这里的意图是什么？
emotionally demanding situations, maybe you're having an argument with someone, take a few minutes, take a day, take a couple hours, and step back and think, what would the highest version of myself, what would the most emotionally intelligent version of myself do in this situation? So the next key skill what we talked about was social awareness, your ability to recognize and interpret cues from other people, being able to communicate with them and feel attached to them and to understand how they're feeling. And in this situation, mindfulness is an ally for emotional and social awareness. To build social awareness, you need to be mindful of what other people are feeling and experiencing, and you need to be able to apply your own experiences to their reactions. There will be subtle
在这种情况下，我的目标是什么？带着这些知识继续前进。把别人当成你自己来看待。而且，你知道的，这是专家的建议。这只是我从互联网和我自己的个人经验中获得的知识。但把别人当成你自己来看待。你在这里想要什么？你想从在某人身上引发反应或以某种方式反应中得到什么？以及你如何利用这一点来参与关系管理和社会调节，这是最后阶段？与他人良好合作是一个过程，正如我们在本集中一次又一次说过的那样，
emotional shifts taking place in other people that you have to be able to recognize. You have to be able to recognize their goals and their objectives. And that, That's where empathy really comes into play. Building that core skill of empathy is so crucial. It is perhaps the most crucial part the same way that social awareness is the hardest part of emotional intelligence. Empathy is something that is really difficult to curate. It's really difficult to develop. But it really sits with in the same kind of area as that self-regulation. Taking a step back, mind mapping out. If I was in this situation, what would I? be feeling, resting on your own self-awareness to think about what would my intentions here be?
始于情感意识以及你识别和理解其他人正在经历的事情的能力。所以这里有一些关键技能。第一种是意识到如何有效地使用非语言交流。不可能避免发送非语言信息。你无法控制脸上对其他人做出反应的肌肉。这就是你无声地传达自己情绪的方式，但这也是如何解读他人的诀窍所在。所以调动你大脑的情感部分来识别某些反应的含义
What would my objectives be in this situation? And move forward with that knowledge. Think about someone else as if they are yourself. And, you know, this is an expert advice. This is just things that I have gained from the internet and from my own personal experience. But think about someone else as if they are yourself. What would you want here? what would you be trying to get out of creating reaction in someone or reacting a certain way? And how do you leverage that in order to engage in relationship management and social regulation, which is the final stage? Working well with others is a process that, as we have said, time and time again in this episode,
其他人是非常重要的，并且可以在改善你的关系中发挥巨大作用。开放式沟通，在看到事情时谈论它们，并用幽默来缓解压力和笑声，它们是冲突和沉重情感局面的天然解药，但要创造那种空间，以便能够与人进行艰难的对话或与人进行必要的对话。最后一种课程和技能是学会将冲突视为拉近与他人距离的机会。冲突和分歧，我们在本上讨论过很多次了，但它们是不可避免的。它们就是那么正常。而且我认为我们在二十岁时的一个大误区是认为我们需要逃避对抗，但事实并非如此
begins with emotional awareness and your ability to recognize and understand what other people are experiencing. So there are a few key skills here. The first one is becoming aware of how effectively to use nonverbal communication. It's impossible to avoid sending nonverbal messages. You cannot control the muscles in your face that react to other people. And that's how you wordlessly convey your own emotions, but it's also the tip of how to read others. So engaging that emotional part of your brain to recognize what certain reactions mean in
始于情感意识以及你识别和理解他人体验的能力。这里有几个关键技能。第一个是学会如何有效地使用非语言沟通。要完全不发送非语言信息是不可能的。你无法控制面部肌肉对他人做出反应的动作。这就是你无声地传达自己情绪的方式，同时这也是解读他人的基础。因此，调动大脑的情感部分去识别某些反应在他人身上意味着什么超级重要，并且可以在改善人际关系方面发挥巨大作用。
others is super important and can play a huge part in improving your relationships. Open communication, talking about things when you see them and using humour to relieve stress and laughter, they're natural antidotes to conflict and to heavy emotional situations, but creating that kind of space to be able to engage and have hard conversations with people or have necessary conversations with people. And the final kind of lesson and skill is learning to see conflict as an opportunity to grow closer to others. Conflict and disagreements, we've talked about it so much on this podcast, but they're inevitable. They are just so normal. And I think a big thing in our 20s is thinking we need to run away from confrontation, but that's just not the
开放的沟通、在发现问题时及时交流，以及用幽默来缓解压力和欢笑，它们是冲突和沉重情感局面的天然解药，但同时也需要创造那种空间，以便能够与他人进行深入交流并开展艰难的对话，或者与他人进行必要的对话。最后一种课程和技能是学会将冲突视为拉近与他人距离的机会。冲突和分歧，我们在本播客中已经讨论过很多次了，但它们是不可避免的。它们是如此正常。我认为在我们二十多岁时一个很大的误区，就是认为我们需要逃避对抗，但事实并非如此。
case. Confrontation and being able to resolve conflict in a healthy, constructive way can strengthen trust between people. So teach yourself and learn and appreciate that conflict doesn't necessarily mean a bad thing. It is a learning opportunity, and it's important for your emotional intelligence to be able to navigate that situation and learn what worked, learn what made you feel better,
情况。对抗以及以健康、建设性的方式解决冲突，能够增进人与人之间的信任。所以，你要教导自己、去学习并理解：冲突并不一定意味着坏事。它是一个学习的机会，能够驾驭这种局面、了解什么方法有效、明白是什么让你感觉更好，这对于你的情商而言至关重要，
but what made other people feel better as well, in order to increase your EQ and kind of reap all those benefits that we've talked about. Thank you so much for listening to this episode. A little bit of a different one, a bit more psychology-based, even though that's the idea of the podcast, delving into the mind, delving into social relationships, all in a day's work.
同时也要明白是什么让其他人也感觉更好，以此来提升你的情商，并收获我们之前讨论过的种种益处。非常感谢收听本期节目。这是一期稍有不同、更偏向心理学的节目，尽管这本身就是本节目的理念——探索心灵、剖析社会关系，这些都是日常工作的一部分。
I found it really interesting to think about these things, think about how I could apply it to my own life, and also knowing that I still have a couple of years to really lay the foundations for an emotionally intelligent life and relationships full with EQ, however you want to apply it. And, you know, in the workplace as well, in my personal life, it is such an important skill. I hope that that has been clear to you based on how much I've said about it in this podcast. But thank you again for listening. As always, if you do feel cool to do so, if you've enjoyed this podcast or some of the other episodes, please leave us a review on either Spotify or Apple Podcasts.
我发现思考这些事情非常有趣，思考我该如何将其应用于自己的生活，并且我也知道，我还有好几年的时间来真正为充满情商的、富有智慧的生活和人际关系打下基础，无论你想如何应用它。而且，你知道的，无论是在职场还是在我的个人生活中，这都是一项如此重要的技能。我希望通过我在本节目中所说的大量内容，这一点已经向你阐述得很清楚了。但还是要再次感谢你的收听。和往常一样，如果你愿意的话，如果你喜欢这个播客或其中的某些单集，请在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上给我们留下评价。
It really allows this community and this platform, this podcast, to grow and to reach new people. So if you've gotten something out of it, I would really appreciate it. It would make my day. and thank you again for listening. Next week we're talking about attachment styles, another social psychology episode, but very, very interesting, nonetheless. Have a beautiful day.
这真的能让这个社群、这个平台以及这个播客得以成长并触及更多新的人群。所以，如果你从中有所收获，我将不胜感激。这会让我的这一天都变得美好。再次感谢你的收听。下周我们将讨论依恋类型，这又是一个社会心理学主题，但同样非常非常有趣。祝你有美好的一天。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在别处可能并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals, to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？它向世界释放出一种信号：你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就非得这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并从《Learn the Hardway》中汲取经验。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是数字 2%，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的惯犯时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们决定亲自采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。收听《The Girlfriends》，相信我，宝贝，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。